[Music]
have you ever had that thing where
you're just
overloaded with information well i got
that this week watching the election
coverage
ever since tuesday i have been watching
the news
non-stop on tv on my laptop on my phone
the stress of it was too much i laid on
the couch
for days i have the same exact thing the
uncertainty of the whole election was
very
anxiety-inducing like watching the news
for hours upon hours and hanging on
their every word made my whole body weak
it's just like a panic you know
a panic that zaps you of all energy
yet at the same time fills you with fear
i was looking at that tv and i was
completely
catatonic
i'm catatonic
there's this guy running for prayers and
he's kind of
a jerking when i think about him winning
well my body stops working
catatonics how i feel thinking bout the
election cause this [ __ ] is not over
could go in
any direction like little bo peep
in her cute little bonnet these critters
giving me the creeps now
i'm catatonic
[Music]
i'm catatonic
[Music]
i'm just a shell of a man i barely
exist even though we all voted they're
still not done and i'm pissed
been nervous about the election since
early last year
i knew that things would get bad but yo
i had no idea
always watching the news always getting
up on it and now it comes at a price
cause now i'm catatonic i'm catted
totally
i'm catatonic
[Music]
dance break yeah
get into it now c
is for couch hey cause my asses of own
it
t is for trying my nerves they freaking
love to flaunt it
ace were really annoyed t is for time
for
a drink o is for oh no what the hell
were you thinking
n is for naught like i'm not doing too
well
i swear i i i i c is for see you in hell
i'm
catatonic
[Music]
i'm cattle tonic
[Music]
tarik davis amber ruffin you know we
both just out here
please make sure to help us just like a
crane or like a dolly
a hand a helping hand you know what drag
me to my chair
[Music]
[Applause]
you